Brian Tracy is one of the legends of
personal development he's the
best-selling author of over 70 books and
has given over 2500 seminars and
workshops in 100 plus countries in this
exclusive interview with Chris Weidner
you'll hear Brian's best advice on the
secrets to high performance thinking the
power of goal setting and strategies to
overcome obstacles and failures and we
got Chris's permission put it up on our
YouTube channel enjoy my guest today is
Brian Tracy one of America's lead
authorities on the development of human
potential and personal Effectiveness
he's a dynamic and inspiring speaker
addressing subjects of personal and
professional development to companies
such as IBM McDonald Douglas and the
million dooll Roundtable he teaches
seminars on leadership self-esteem goals
and strategies creativity and practical
ideas to get results fast he's authored
many books including turbo coach million
dooll habits and the 100 absolutely
unbreakable laws of business success
welcome Brian thank you Chris good to
have you here thank you it's a pleasure
yeah you have been a mentor to me
through your books and your tapes and
millions of other people and so one of
the things that I'm really excited about
to have you here we're going to talk
about some of the books and the audio
programs and all those principles um but
as I mentioned in the opening one of the
things that I really like to help people
do is see the person behind the
personality because at your level most
people see you on a stage in front of a
th000 2,000 5,000 10,000 people and they
don't get to have this chance you know
to just sit down with the man the woman
uh who they get to see in these big
Arenas and the the big seminars and just
just sit there and find out about their
life and so I thought it would be
interesting for our viewers to find out
the person behind the personality so
tell me a little bit about yourself your
your family where you live uh some of
those things to help people get to know
you a little bit better well I was born
in Canada I was born in Prince Edward
Island which is as close as you can get
to uh England without being on a ship
and during the war and I grew up in
Toronto and then my family moved to
California so I grew up in California
and my uh whole experience is American
uh I love America I'm a passionate
American Patriot and then my family
moved back to uh Vancouver British
Columbia when I was 16 I finished high
school there uh I didn't finish but I'm
finished high school yeah uh worked at
laboring jobs for several years and then
went traveling spent eight years
traveling around the world now traveled
in 90 countries I've spoken in 42
countries since I became a speaker and
uh I began asking the question why is it
that some people are more successful
than others and coming from a poor
background with no money and high school
dropout and digging ditches and washing
dishes and all of that stuff I was
really frustrated I could tell you
within a dollar how much money I had in
my pocket for several years because I
had no money I slept on the ground I
slept in my car an old car um I uh I
went on unemployment once I went on
welfare once just once in those days
they didn't encourage you to go on
welfare uh they said if we ever see you
in here again you're going to be in big
trouble and I'll tell you they were mean
about
it so went back to work uh we should try
that a little bit more yeah but uh I
finally got into sales I couldn't get a
job in laboring so I got into sales
straight commission sales knocking on
doors getting up in the morning I used
to get up in the morning at at 6:00 in
the morning I'd be in the parking lot
7:00 waiting for people to come to work
and I knock on doors all day long I say
I used to run from place to place so I
could be rejected more often uh and I
been remember one month I made 504 calls
and no sales and I just went from place
to place I was just so frustrated and
just barely hanging on by my fingernails
living in a little boarding house a
little room um and one day I went to the
top salesman of my
company and I said um what are you doing
differently from me he was making 10
times as much as anybody else and he
said well show me your presentation I'll
critique it for you I said well you show
me yours and I'll show you mine because
I didn't know what a presentation was I
was using what what I call the blah blah
cell I'd find somebody go blah blah blah
blah blah and so on and and he said well
no no selling is a logical and orderly
process that you follow if you want to
make sales and he showed me the process
he showed me instead instead of talking
all the time to ask questions find out
if the person is a real Prospect find
out establish Rapport find out their
needs present show our product ask it
answer their questions close the sale
get more sale I had no idea it was a
process I was just the light went on I
still remember to this day I can
remember when when when I the light went
on you know there's an old saying the
more you do of what you're doing the
more you get at what you've got and uh
Abraham Asel used to say if if the only
tool you have is a hammer then the whole
world looks like a
nail well the only tool I had was blah
blah just going from place to place and
going blah blah about my product he said
no no no this a process it's like a
recipe if you follow the recipe you can
prepare the dish now the Breakthrough
for me was very simple is that there's a
cause and effect relationship with
everything there's a reason everything
happens all business skills are
learnable all sales skills are learnable
all money-making skills are learnable
they are learnable skills everybody who
has them didn't have them now they have
them well they had to learn them just
like typing with a typewriter or using a
cell phone or or reading or writing or
anything they're all learnable skills
and anybody can learn the skills and
anybody right 95% of the population can
learn virtually any business or any
sales or any money-making skill once
you've learned the skill you can use it
over and over again so if you learned a
way to make money then you can use that
over and over again and each time you
use it you get better at it and each
time you get better at it takes you less
time to get the same result and that's
why some people are more successful than
others that's why people go from Rags to
Riches that's why some people are rich
and other people are poor people who are
rich found a usually they specialized
they found and learned a success skill
success sales business management you
perfect example uh the high road to
financial success in our society is
entrepreneurship starting and building a
business uh 70% of adults want to start
and build a business um 80% of all
self-made billionaires come from
self-owned
businesses well what they find is that
most people go broke when they start a
business and the research is exhaustive
and all the answers of been found the
reason is because they don't know what
they're doing they're flying by the seat
of their pants so they're making things
up as they go along and they're running
it against the clock until they run out
of money and then they go back and work
for wages but then you have on the other
hand you have serial entrepreneurs
Richard Branson is most famous but you
have serial entrepreneurs to start
business after business after business
everyone is successful start it build it
sell it start it build it sell it how
how can this be it's because they're
following a recipe and if you learn the
recipe you can start one business after
another because as Richard Branson said
if you can be successful in one business
you can be successful in any business
cuz the principles remain the same mhm
wow and varied businesses from
telephones to Airlines to all the
businesses he started basic principles
Remain the what I learned is that you
can learn any skill you need to learn to
achieve any goal you can set for
yourself and for for me coming from so
far behind I thought I was first um I
was overwhelmed by the thought and so I
went out when I got into Sales
Management I did I learned how to sell
and I just sold and sold I couldn't
couldn't believe how how much I could
sell within a year I'd gone from living
in a boarding house to having apartments
in three cities to flying on Jets to
dining in the best restaurants and never
having less than $1,000 and $20 bills in
my pocket I have a Swiss bank account I
mean it was just unbelievable I couldn't
and G literally from 24 to 25 why it's
because I learned the ways to sell and I
practiced it over and over again I got
better and better at it made more and
more
sales not mysterious then I got into
Sales Management failed completely and I
realized who sales management is very
different from sales so I went back and
I spoke to sales managers and I read the
books and the Articles and I learned how
to do I learned the recipes learned the
formulas there's a there's a the
principle I learned I say that all of
success is is combinations and recipes
and formulas a combination is like a
combination lock if you have the three
numbers and you turn to the numbers in
sequence the lock opens and the lock
doesn't
care know if you if you do what are the
successful people do then the lock opens
for you if if you don't the lock doesn't
care I say success is just like a
combination lock but with more numbers
like just find out the numbers turn to
the numbers in the proper sequence and
it opens for you and that's why people
can come to America from 194 different
countries now and become successful
because what the Smart Ones do and I've
spoken to thousands of them they get
here and they ask around they look at
members of their Community or successful
they say how does it work in this
country they say this is this is the
combination this is the formula ah so
they follow the formula till they Master
it 10 years later still not speaking
English half the time they've got large
businesses they're millionaires their
kids are in Harvard and everything else
Jesus you're lucky they were lucky they
they never knew these things before
anyway so the second thing is is is
recipes and what I say is is a recipe is
a combination of ingredients in a
certain way and if anybody has ever
developed a favorite recipe then they
they got the recipe they took it home
they got the ingredients and they made
it up and sometimes I'll ask my audience
I say how how did it taste the first
time and they not very good now here's
an here's an important thing nothing
works the first time nothing works the
first five or 10 times sometimes you'll
have to work at something for years
before it works some of the biggest
breakthroughs in history took six seven
years yeah perfect example the fax
machine the fax machine was developed by
the way at the same time that Federal
Express was trying to develop an
electronic message center they spent
$185 million at it somebody invented a
fax machine
and Federal Express wrote off their
investment because the fax machine could
do it almost at no cost but it took
almost six or seven years before the fax
machine hit critical mass almost all of
us remember uh oh have you got a fax
machine no but the people down all
Allway do we can go down and use their
fax machine remember that now kids have
fax machines well once it took off it's
sold by the tens of millions literally
transform the world cell phones stragg
on you might used to have have a
suitcase for a cell phone it took five
or six or seven years and suddenly they
got the technology right and the price
right
boom personal computers each one of
these things at a certain point the the
the IBM best research at IBM said the
World Market for personal computers
there no more than 3 to 400 units MH
that's what they said in what
1975 76 right so they just walked away
from it then Apple came along and built
their computer in a garage and the World
Market became 100 billion units uh so
when you start off with a new recipe
it's not going to work now what happens
when people get a new idea and they put
it all together and try it out and it
doesn't work they give up but the person
who has tasted a dish let's say you and
I go to a friend's house or a restaurant
has they really great this I have this
recipe and say yeah take the recipe home
and we and we try it and it Tes tastes
terrible we say wait a minute we have an
advantage we know this can taste good
because we have tasted it we're not
positive thinkers we're not wishing and
hoping and drink we know it's it's just
a matter of going back and looking at
the way we mixed it and they usually
call the person who cooked it for him
say I cooked it but didn't taste that
way and then they get some help yeah do
a little bit of this do that did you
remember to do this or wait let us sit
and so on I have a good friend one of my
clients and he he started off in sales
and uh his for six months he spun his
wheels and sold nothing and then he got
a hold of my psychology of selling and
he told me go over lunch because he he
had hired me to address his organization
which was 2,000 people live and 85,000
people by satellite and so we're talking
over Lun he said you know you changed my
life you took me from rag to Rich he now
a very wealthy person multiple
businesses and so on and he said it was
that cause and effect thing in your
program here I was I've been selling for
six months I couldn't sell anything I
was really desperate and I was in my 20s
had a family de feat and then I got that
program and I listened to it and it said
if you put in the right causes you'll
get the right effects well the effect I
wanted was sell was sales I wanted to
make money but I must I really I must be
I must not be putting in the right
causes so like a a recipe went back and
he looked at each ingredient and he said
oh I have to do more of this and less of
that I have to say and he began to
change his for sales recipe if you like
within six more months he was top in his
company within three more years he was
top in the country today he's worth
about $21 million he's very successful
he says that caus and effect he said if
you just find out what other people have
done to achieve the same result you'll
achieve it yourself yeah yeah yeah so
the the third thing I talk about is
formulas and and there's a when you say
this is a scientific formula or this has
been this is
scientific what does that mean well I
came across this great concept recently
and the word that the scientists use is
replicability it's replicable if it is a
truly scientific formula I say it may
have been developed over many years by
Geniuses but now it can be used
successfully by
morons and when you understand and that
that's why you see people I say there's
nothing will make you matter than to see
somebody dumber than you making more
money than you yeah how could that
person be making more money they're so
dumb they can't find their behind with
both hands well the answer is they found
a scientific formula a success we call
it a success formula for their
particular field whether it's running a
business or recipe as or or selling or
making money or anything else I have a
good friend we were here at Dallas
talking I have a good friend here in
Dallas who heard that you could buy
houses and you could accumulate houses
by buying them at the proper prices and
then financing them and so on well he
had just gone broke in a business and he
heard about this and he looked at people
who were doing it it do not look like
they were Road scholar and so he said
I'm going to buy 100 houses and he went
out and over the next three years he
bought and accumulated a 100 houses now
here's what happens the first house was
very hard he had to look at a lot of
houses he had to do a lot of inspections
he had to the the first one is always
hard first sale is the hardest you know
the first person you higher as a
entrepreneur is the hardest but then he
realized there was a system to this so
he attended a couple of courses and he
read the books and he learned the system
and then he bought a second house and he
was able to finance in and finance out
of that and then a third house start off
with no money he said it's go with 100
houses in 3 years he had 100 houses and
about $3 million in equity wow he said
well it works and now he can probably
drive down a street see a house for sale
decide instantaneously whether he's
going pick up the phone and get a deal
done in a day yeah because he learned it
it's easy to do for him was hard at the
beginning it was hard at the beginning
made a lot of mistakes and and what
happens with most people when they make
mistakes at the beginning they think
that they may be must be deficient in
some way or the systems deficient or the
products deficient no this is the price
that nature demands for success is you
must fail so all great successes have
been great failures successful people
fail over and over again whereas
unsuccessful people fail once and quick
mhm mhm it reminds me GK Chester in
speaking he said uh it's not that it's
been tried and found wanting it's been
found difficult and left untried do you
think I mean do you think that that's
really why most people never achieve
that kind of thing is because they it
gets hard and they just stop I mean is
it is it as simple as that well almost
all of us all of us have deep deep down
fears of failure yeah and it's the
greatest single obstacle to a success
and it's very easily triggered it's very
easily triggered by any kind of
frustration like we're on our our way to
work and we've got an appointment and
the traffic jam coming over here today
there was a traffic jam on the other
side car was on fire they blocked off
the entire freeway for 25 miles
everything was stopped well got person
gets on there in the traffic jam and and
I'm going to miss the appointment I'm
going to miss the deal I'm going to miss
everything else oh damn and and they and
they they develop what it's called
learned helplessness is they feel
helpless I can't do anything then next
time they think well what's the use so
don't even bother at all and eventually
I said they they talk themselves in and
talk themselves right out of doing what
is necessary for Success where
successful people they say Okay
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
what's the next thing I I was uh stuck
in a traffic jam recently I was driving
along the freeway and I was out in the
countryside and and you could see you're
driving along about 7080 mes hour and
suddenly every all the cars are stopping
you're stopping stopping do you realize
there there's a jam up there and you
can't see but you can see way ahead car
is jamming the other side's whipping
along so I'm sitting there and just
almost at an offramp and uh you're
thinking well should I sit in giraffic
and wait and then I saw a couple of guys
in pickups four-wheel drives SUVs going
right up the side of the ramp back onto
the road they I mean they driving off
the road D driving down the the uh the
uh the Boulevard and right up the ramp
and under the road and getting out and
finding another route and I thought
that's for me so I so I turned off and I
drove and drove and drove and I finally
drove all the way around this traffic J
which was about 15 20 mi long wow Got
Back back onto the freeway and was empty
freeway was like it's like an empty
parking lot and got I drove home well I
learned later that a semi had turned
over and the traffic was backed up for 3
hours the entire afternoon this was
about 2:00 the entire afternoon those
people who did not move quickly were sto
now there's a metaphor there I mean
that's that's what successful people can
do in life if things don't work they try
something else they move quickly I don't
say oh well maybe things will get better
you know the mass is just sit there and
go I wonder why we're not moving that's
right so you find that entrepreneurs are
very fast on their feet yeah you know
the the here in Dallas they made that
movie actually it was in Houston Apollo
13 and Eugene CR was famous for that
line um where he stands up and he tells
everybody he said ladies and gentlemen
he said there's people talking about
what we will do and how we will explain
it if it doesn't work out and they all
die and people are thinking of covering
themselves I want to tell you something
failure is not an option yeah failure is
not an option
and uh that has to be your philosophy as
far as I'm concerned failure is not an
option the the possibility of failure is
is not even considered there will be
temporary setbacks and defeats and
disappointments uh most self-made
millionaires have been broke 2.3 times
broke or nearly broke 2.3 times before
they made it some of the most successful
people in America at one time Henry Ford
was the richest man in America he was
bankrupt the age of 40 third time most
most amazing story just never sto
stopped and that's the most wonderful
thing if you ask what's the key to the
key to success is to become Unstoppable
well that's one of the amazing things
about sitting here with successful
people like yourself is I hear it over
and over and over I was born in poverty
you know Albert men I was born in Ghana
in a hut you know and and I like for the
viewers to see everybody saying I've had
obstacles I had you know cancer I had I
was born into poverty and it it helps
people say wow if they can do it I can
do it because there's nothing that stops
me from that now here's here's a couple
of quick points and I I said tell this
to my my audiences I say remember this
nobody is better than you and nobody is
smarter than you get that out of your
head because that is a killer that's a
self- sabotaging idea you see somebody
doing better than you the natural
conclusion is if he or she is doing
better than you must be better no
they're not better than you they're not
smarter than you they just learned the
cause and effect relationships before
you did some of them are idiots but what
they thought and but but an idiot who's
got the right formula will be successful
whereas a genius who doesn't driving a
taxi cap at the age of 50 so nobody's
smarter than you nobody's better than
you you have more intelligence and
potential than you could ever use in 100
lifetimes is the the question is if it
doesn't work try something else and the
it's very much like like working out
with weights if you want to build muscle
I used to be a a bodybuilder what you do
is you pump iron and pumping iron what
you do is you pump blood into your
muscles and it breaks the capillaries it
actually is an act of Destruction and
then your body repairs itself and builds
new capillaries around which is how you
build muscles and it's the same thing
with your mind is when you have
experiences and you have setbacks that
are distressing and you learn from them
your mind pumps iron you get smarter you
become quicker you become more alert you
become more aware there's a price that
you pay you can't go from innocence to
success in a highly competitive Society
without getting bruised a bit it's like
someone wants to be a championship boxer
just doesn't want to get
punched you know they say everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to
die well everybody wants to be rich but
nobody wants to take the pounding that
is necessary to be financially
independent just keep remembering
failure is not an option I'm unstoppable
nobody's smarter than me nobody's better
than me if they're doing better it's
because they figured out the formula
before me but if hundreds of thousands
of millions of people America today has
8.2 million millionaires almost all of
whom are
self-made uh my daughter was was married
in August and uh my first daughter and
four children daughter two boys and a
daughter and married to a wonderful uh
young man comes from a uh good family
just and and so we they she decided she
wanted to have the wedding at our home
and so we sat down and you never want to
talk about how much it costs they they
won't even tell me afterwards because
it's too heartbreaking I have three
daughters so don't tell me that the
costs are unbelievable whatever whatever
whatever number they give you at the as
the maximum maximum number multiply it
by two um anyway so so so in order to
accommodate 160 people they had this
beautiful tent like something out of the
Arabian nights and bands and music and
sushi bars and and and karaoke and
flowers that you cannot believe
everything and so we're at this U at at
the wedding reception after the wedding
and my my son-in-law Christina's husband
has family they brought the whole family
down and they're all on our house from
from Los Angeles in 90 90 minute 2 2hour
drive and they're all standing around
and of course there's a lot of you know
face here we want to be able to put on a
wonderful wedding for your daughter and
these people are wealthy they own large
businesses and law firms and everything
else so they brought them all down none
of them I've ever been there before
looking around it's not a bad house and
the wedding is beautiful and everything
is so I'm sitting there talking to two
of them the most successful of the all
and uh they said this is a beautiful
house um Brian done a wonderful job here
I said well I can't tell you how happy I
am to be able to do this for my daughter
especially since I started with nothing
and I've made it everything I've done by
myself and and the other person who's in
charge of 102 lawyer law firm with 250
staff supporting the lawyers multi
multimillion he said well I started with
nothing too he said when you know when I
got out of school I had nothing my
family had nothing the guy next to him
it's a senior partis well I have nothing
then they were referring to my my I call
my father-in-law I the father of my my
son-in-law Larry started with nothing
too we're talking about everybody
started with nothing everywhere I go I
talk to my best friend one of my best
friends who's got now a real estate
Fortune about $25 million he's a
immigrant came over it started with
nothing I find that this a story of
America everybody starts with nothing
people well I don't have anything to
start off with well join the crowd well
even the people on the Forbes 400 the
people who inherited it they got it from
somebody who started with nothing it
always is traced back to nobody started
with nothing yeah it's and it's the most
amazing joh it's amazing how many
self-made billionaires there are the
richest people in America if you start
to look at the richest people in America
I follow this and you follow it number
one Bill Gates started with nothing you
know good education good family but
nothing
self-made and number two Warren Buffett
started with nothing self made number
three um probably Larry Ellison Oracle
started with nothing Michael Dell
started with nothing Paul Allen started
with nothing and the next five are the
descendants of Sam Walton who started
with nothing exactly and at the end he
basically was still driving that old
blue pickup truck you know cuz he didn't
need anything yeah I mean just I mean
the the richest people in our country
and most respected yeah now here's
here's the difference between America
and most of the world I speak all over
the world I speak French German Spanish
I speak do all kinds of seminars
multiple languages and cultures but one
of the differences in America is that if
you started a business and you failed in
the business and I meet you um for for
dinner socially I say how's your
business going you say well I went
busted I had to shut the doors went
bankrupt my reaction would be geez
that's amazing what happened no I did
this I didn't do that well what would
you do next time well I do little this
what are your plans while we start
another business in other words in
America going bankrupt is not a mark of
Shame it's it's a it's a mark of
maturity it's means it means that you
took a chance you gave a shot and it
didn't work and whenever you speak to a
person went bankrupt they're talking
about their next business their next
project in America you can start a
business within 24 hours MH if you go on
the internet you do it even faster than
that we have the fastest rate of do
business formation of any country in the
world we have the we have the most
entrepreneurial country in the world
according to the oecd in Paris we have
more people starting more businesses in
more areas because you can start a
business by just saying I think I we'll
have a business you and I could say
Chris why don't we start a business okay
and we're in business we can we we start
buying and selling before we get any
papers signed you said let's buy some
stuff from these guys and sell it okay
great I'll put in some money you put in
some money we're in business before we
walk out of the building yeah we can do
that that's not possible in 95% of the
world's countries so so so America is
wonderful and if and if we fail what do
we try something else yeah that's the
attitude that all successful people have
I always find it interesting you know we
talk about his America great and all
these and and the fact is if you if you
open the borders up the Earth would tilt
off its axis because everybody would
rotate over to America because everybody
wants to pursue it's the American dream
nobody talks about the Chinese dream or
the European Dream It's the American
dream of being able to build your own
wealth and and set your own destiny and
that type of thing hey there it's Chris
Weidner and I hope that you're enjoying
this interview that I did with one of
the legends of personal development and
if you'd like even more information and
great resources from the legends of
personal development all you have to do
is click on the link below in the
description and I've got a plenty more
for you so with that let's get back to
the interview one of the um things I
wanted to ask you about knowing you were
going to be on the show I I got a whole
list of things I wanted to talk to you
about secrets of self-made Millionaires
and I know that that's one of your major
courses of research what are some of the
the secrets of self-made millionaires
the people who start with nothing like
we've been talking about and they end up
at the end with a big stash millionaires
what what are what are the secrets of
that my book The Secrets the 21 success
secrets of self-made millionaires has
just 21 qualities and I won't give you
all of them but but they're very simple
and and and lacking the absence of any
one of them can be fatal I say first of
all um Dream Big Dreams I found that the
number one reason that people do not
become wealthy is because it never
occurs to them that they can become
wealthy it never occurs to them and so
uh they never say hey I can become
wealthy too because if you've been
brought up in a poor background if you
associate with people who don't have
much money if you've been broke or you
know have too much month at the end of
the money uh for too long it'll never
Dawn on you that it's possible to do it
any other way you get you fall into it a
negative comfort zone the number two
reason that people don't become Su
successful is they never make a decision
to oh I'd like to and I want to and I
hope to and I wish to and so on but they
don't make a decision because if you
make a decision that by gum I'm going to
do it and you'll find that every
successful person is a decisive person
at a certain point they said all right
I'm going to do it I'm going to get in
here in Texas they have this great card
game Texas holdom or or yeah Texas hold
now in Texas holdom which is one of the
most popular games all this there's that
point in Texas Holdem where you go all
in yeah all the chips in the middle now
it can be be because you're you're down
to your last few chips and you have no
choice because you can't match to
anybody else or it can be because you
got a great hand but you go all in they
don't play Texas Hold of in any other
country in the world because in America
we go all in if we we make a decision
and we go all in if we lose it then we
pick ourselves up and try it again so uh
first is they is they um never never
curse and they don't decide to and then
if they do decide to they
procrastinate and they say well I'm
going to but not yet they they they say
I first of all I'm going to take a brief
vacation to a wonderful uh fantasy place
called someday aisle and so they go to
someday aisle someday I'll give that a
chance someday I'll read that book and
someday I'll set some goals someday I'll
live within my means and save some money
and so on as I live on some day aisle
for the rest of their lives and so it
goes on like that so I say Dream Big
Dreams and just remember and I finished
to talk to to 800 people just last week
and I was talking to them about the
strategies of successful entrepreneurs
and at the end I said remember this 5%
of adults in our society are going to
become millionaires but we don't know
who they are we know that of any hundred
adults walking around today at the end
of their or halfway through their career
five will be millionaires but because of
the uncertainty principle we don't know
just exactly which ones they are I say
so let's take this room and let's say
not 5% of the people in this room let's
say 100% of the people in this room are
going to be in the 5% so I want you to
just say these words I am a millionaire
everybody said I am a millionaire and
good now from this moment on make that
come true make it come true decide to
and take action on it and everybody's
really happy with that concept because
it never occurred to the thing I'm a
millionaire and they probably felt
uncomfortable the first time or the
first five times that you had him say it
yeah and then I said remember everybody
who's Rich today was once poor everybody
at the top as once at the bottom and
nobody's better than you nobody's
smarter than you so there's 100,000 ways
that you could become millionaires I
said before we have 8.2 million
millionaires that means we have hundreds
of thousands and millions of men and
women who started with nothing and
become
millionaires uh so if all of those
people can do it hundreds of thousands
and millions of them can do it then so
can you just make a decision and if you
took it all away from them and
redistributed the wealth to everybody
which some people would love to do you
and I wouldn't agree with
it all out give it 20 years 30 years
what's going to happen give it one or
two give it one or two years yeah
exactly it's all going to gravitate
right back to those people who learn how
to do it yeah it's like in in Russia
they gave away you know State companies
and some companies countries they will
um what what they what's the word I'm
looking for they will nationalize that
or denationalize they'll take a state
bank or a state Railroad and give out
shares to everybody you within a year or
two most of the shares are in the hands
of a few people they've bought them all
up
um you know you're were talking about
tilting the world on its aess U my
friend Bill Bennett who used to be the
Secretary of Education was once asked by
a high school student what is the um how
can you tell a good country um From a
Bad Country he said because we read all
these negative things in the paper about
America right now America is the most
prosperous country in the history of the
world there is more Economic Opportunity
more possibilities greater longevity
faster levels of growth lower levels of
unemployment higher levels of home
ownership and more possibilities than
any other country at any other time in
human history this is the best country
this is this is the dream this is the
golden age that man has dreamed about
for years and years and years and yet
four out of five stories in the Press
condemn the American economy the
majority of Americans today believe that
America is in a recession they say oh
I'm doing really well but just read the
papers America's in a recession it has
never been better anyway so they asked
Bill Bennett the student asked Bill
Bennett how can you tell with if a
country is a good country or not with
everything we read he said well it's
very simple he said you use the gate
test and what is the gate test he said
you just raise the gate and watch which
way the people go exactly is that great
that's what you were saying about
tilting the AC you know we don't even
have to raise the gate I mean we have to
have thousands of people basically
almost arm to arm on on the borders to
keep people out because everybody wants
to come here from every country in the
world there's no country in the world
people trying to get into no other
country they're not trying to jam into
Germany or France or Russia or China or
Japan or anywhere else and nobody else
has immigration problems that's right do
you know do you know that that that
America um is is the most generous
country in the world is that we give
more in charity nationally and
internationally than all the other
countries in the world put together and
they say oh we only give 1.6.1 16% of
our gross national product but they
don't realize that America most giving
is private giving sure it's by the tens
of billions you know the charity alone
was last year was $186 billion and it
goes up every single year no matter how
much they change the taxes people give
more and more and more tens of millions
look at the gates have given what 46
billion doar to to Charities we take in
more immigrant legally about illegally
each year that all the rest of the
countries in the world put together
people always say America is this
America is that yes we're the most
generous we're the most open we're the
most giving the most prosperous Society
in history so you can never
underestimate the power of Envy The
Power of Envy explains almost everything
that's happening in our world today well
and and uh I was talking to Albert menah
at the same table and he said that's
what drove him he was in Ghana they put
a they put a movie an American movie up
on a a side of a building right and he
said everybody has shoes in that movie
everybody they're all wearing shoes he
had never seen a fork before and and or
a spoon he he didn't they always ate
with SP o o n and and and that's what
drives them they see yeah they see
what and they want to they want to move
here because of the American dream yeah
well you know there's there was a a MIG
pilot the man who flew the Russian Mig
out of uh Russia into hio in Japan many
years ago was a big big story big
controversy and everything else well
they asked him why he defected he said
well he was a colonel in the so in
Soviet Air Force he said well the they
taken the movie The Grapes of Wrath
staring Henry Fonda and they were
playing it all over the country it was a
30 1935 movie okay they were playing it
all over the country as though this was
an actual depiction of America today
Dust Bowl
and everything else and people kept
going back to see the movie and the
Russians thought this was a great
propaganda coup people going back and
then they asked them why they said the
poorest people in America have got cars
and they had to pull the movie from
every screen in Russia because it made
every he said I want to go to a place
where the poor people have cars I have a
good friend from India who who was
talking to to a friend of his he's
immigrant here very successful he
talking to a friend of his in India said
all I do want to do in my life is is go
to America he said why he said I want to
go to a land where the poor people are
[Music]
[Applause]
fat because you
know which is which is the case most
amazing darn thing Bill Gates uh has
been very generous in speaking to
University students and he was once
asked a question which came up several
times so he asked answered it the same
way he said if a person was standing
behind a screen and you could only ask
him one question you Bill Gates richest
man in the world ask him one question um
uh and the and the and the question uh
was to determine his economic prospects
okay what question would you ask and he
said the question is very simple I said
what country do you live in because if
you live in the United States your
economic prospects are better than if
you live anywhere else in the world your
chances you're you're in the ball game
yeah and and then he then later on he
was piggyback they said well if you
could ask him a second question what
would it be and he would say what is
your level of
Education what country do you live in
what is your level of educ
those two will more predict your success
than anything else now when I was in
my teens I fail out of high school when
I was in my 30s I went back and took an
entire MBA program at leading University
and I didn't learn a damn thing and and
I and I share this with my audiences
because a lot of people have this this
uncomfortable feeling that they really
can't be successful because they didn't
get a great degree so one of the things
I emphasize is forget about it what I
discovered and I want to take in the MBA
I do a lot of research is that two years
after you leave school whatever School
you leave whether it's Harvard or huab
buuck university two years after you
leave school and start work nobody cares
about what school you went to for the
rest of your life all they care about is
your performance on the job now and you
can get the best education by reading
practical stuff by listening to
practical programs by listening to
practical audios and seeing practical
DVDs you can learn more in a few hours
with someone like you or I who's been
out there in the front trenches sharing
really practical stuff than you could in
hours and hours and hours of the
university the very best education is
self-directed education and there's a
reason for this if you go to the
university 95% of what they teach you is
unusable and you'll forget it by the
time you get home after graduation but
if you are learning self-directed
everything you learn you have selected
because it will help you now to do your
job better so you're a self-directed
education if you have the discipline to
do it worth 10 20 times the university
education so never let yourself be held
back because you feel you lacked a
formal education because most of those
people with formal educations are
working for people who dropped out of
high school yeah yeah yeah speaking of
practical stuff one of the my favorite
titles of anything you've ever done
ultimately very practical because it has
to do with what we do every day eat the
frog or eat that frog eat that frog eat
that frog okay tell us about that
because I I think it's just a brilliant
title for one thing it's engaging and
and intrigu what is that well it's based
on a little story it says if the first
thing you do when you get up in the
morning is you eat a live frog then
you'll have the pleasure of knowing
throughout the day that's probably the
worst thing that's going to happen to
you all day long right now your live
frog is your biggest and ugliest task
it's the one that will make the biggest
difference in your life the one that
counts the most the one has the greatest
impact and it's also the one you're most
likely to procrastinate on so then
there's two corollaries to eating the
frog one is if uh you have to eat two
frogs eat the ugliest one
first and the second corollary is if you
have to eat the Frog at all it doesn't
pay to sit and look at it for too long
just get on with it so so so here's the
key to success uh here's one of the
great keys to success is make a list of
everything you have to do each day and
go over the list and say if I could only
do one thing on this list which one
thing would have the greatest positive
impact on my life and career put a one
next to that and then say ask the
question again if I could only do two
things two and write it down to seven
and then start on number one and if you
can start on number one and discipline
yourself to stay at number one until
it's finished you will double your
productivity that day if you do this
repeatedly you will soon develop a habit
of starting on number one you will
double your productivity and double it
again and double it again and become a
great success in life and if you can't
do that you'll always have to work for
someone else who will supervise you and
hold your own hold your feet to the fire
and make you do it and so that's the
choice is that that only 2% of the
American population 2 to 3% have the
ability to discipline themselves to do
their most important task and do only
that until it's done and those people
make all the money the top 1% of
Americans pay
34.4 7% of the income taxes because the
top 1% make that much money the top 5%
pay you know 45% the top 10% pay 55%
that the bottom three point the bottom
50 % of Americans pay 3.4% of all the
taxes in other words they pay nothing
they're off the rules that's why they
always vote for more taxes right so I
want to talk about another one of your
uh programs which is I'm I'm guessing
it's probably your best selling of all
time psychology of selling is that well
the psychology of selling is the
bestselling audio program on sales in
the history of the world right it's not
my best selling because I my my
psychology of achievement is sold even
more oh it is okay but psychology of
selling has uh been a top seller in 16
languages in 24 countries and it's the
best seller in the English language
outsold all other programs ever produced
put together more people have become
millionaires listening to psychology of
selling in sales than any other single
influence so it's it's it's really good
so tell me the principles that are
behind that obviously it's a multi-d uh
program but what are the basic
principles of the psychology of selling
well the the the the starting off
principle is this is that top salese
have high self-esteem which means they
like themselves and respect themselves
and value themselves the word is they
feel comfortable in their own skin and
when you genuinely like yourself you you
you're not continually preoccupied with
what other people might think of you you
just like yourself so therefore you like
other people and the more you like other
people the more they like you back and
the more they want to buy from you and
recommend you to their friends so that's
the starting point of the psychology of
selling is that 80 90% of your success
is going to be determined by how well
you get along with others by how much
they like you because because there's a
there's a factor that says that people
will not buy from you unless they like
you and trust you and starts with liking
yourself yes it starts with liking
yourself what if you don't I mean there
are people out there who who they don't
and maybe it's self-confidence they
don't feel confident about themselves
they they they're unsure of themselves
how do you get that I mean it's it's not
something you go well today I'm going to
like myself
okay one of the things we teach people
to just say continually throughout the
day like lifting weights it keep saying
I like myself I like myself I like
myself I like myself and then we say
make other people like themselves now
the way that you make other people like
themselves you make other people feel
important which is what Dale Carnegie
wrote 75 years ago is just make people
feel important make them feel
appreciated thank them uh congratulate
them appraise them admire them be a nice
person don't argue with them just be a
nice just be a genuinely nice person the
number one word to describe the highest
paid salespeople in every field in
America is he or she is a nice person
why do you buy from that company why do
you buy from that person well he she
they they're nice people but what about
with the product you can get it cheaper
somewhere else get better yeah I might
prefer to go they're nice people they're
really nice people they Tre they treat
me well when I phone up they always
treat me well when when I have a problem
they treat me well so you find that your
your most successful people are nice
people but the nicest is is a genuine
expression of their self-esteem so let's
say a person starts off with low
self-esteem as I did as you did
everybody does all right well
self-esteem is like physical fitness
it's a form of mental Fitness how do you
become mentally fit
well what we find is that that
self-esteem comes from feeling that
you're valuable feeling that you're a
winner so how do you feel like a winner
will you win how do you win is you set
goals and you make plans to achieve the
goals and you work on your major goals
each day and each time you take a step
toward achieving a goal that you set for
yourself you like yourself you respect
yourself your self-confidence and
self-esteem goes up and when you
accomplish a goal you get a surge of
self-esteem your brain releases
endorphins you feel happy happy and
elate you like other people you know
when I'm in love I feel 10t tall you
know everybody loves a lover remember
that song well that's when when you're
successful you feel wonderful about
yourself and that's why they say the
very best time to make a sale is right
after having made a sale because when
you make a sale you get this this Rush
of endorphin you feel happy and when you
go in to see another person the person
has not changed but you've changed
you're more positive you're warmer
you're more you have more energy you're
more enthusiastic people just love to be
around you and sometimes you can get
into a role where you make several sales
in a day at the end of the day you're
just just racing because you're having
so much success so do you think it's
incremental that that you everybody
starts here and you might you would
never feel comfortable in a room full of
billionaires but then you make $100,000
and now you're saying hey I feel
comfortable around these people that
make $100,000 then pretty soon I'm a
millionaire and now I is it is it just a
matter of getting ourselves to the next
level and and feeling yeah a sense of
belonging there you know there there's
there's one of the laws I have a whole
lot of laws in one of my programs I have
something like aund Laws of Success what
is called the law of incremental
Improvement the law of incremental
Improvement says nobody leaps from
average to Superior it's one step at a
time and everybody who is successful is
impatient so they say i' like to be
wealthy well they when now now well
yesterday okay you've made the decision
but be prepared to put in the time yeah
I I say to to be get to the top of your
field you must become very good at what
you do
this is one of the secrets of self-made
millionaires first of all they have Big
Dreams second of all they accept
responsibility they third them all they
third of all they commit themselves to
becoming excellent at what they do uh
fourth of all they set clear goals have
a clear sense of direction they
constantly upgrade their skills they're
teachable they learn so so we say to be
in the top 10% in your field you're
going to have to be in the top 10% in
your field which means you're going to
have to become very good at what you do
there's no average there's no high pay
for average performance and so how long
does it take to get into the top 10 10%
this there's 50 years of studies on the
subject of Mastery how long does it take
for a person to achieve Mastery average
seven years seven years and 10,000 hours
of hard work and you and I are our
speakers and one of the things when I
started off speaking I would see other
speakers who spoke so fluently and
fluidly and beautifully you have some of
them on this show like Zig Ziggler
Dennis we wow these people are so
competent they're so smooth their timing
is beautiful and of course I when you
start off you're rough and you have good
ideas and enthusiasm but you're you know
you're you're unpolished as I say well
then I learned something very valuable
is that success in speaking comes from
the number of hours you speak if you
speak a few hours a year it'll take you
a lifetime you'll never be good if you
speak like the professionals do uh 100
talks a year average of 3 hours of talk
300 to 500 hours a year after 10 years
uh you you've done U 3,000 hours after
20 years you've done 6,000 hours and
nothing replaces the hours on your feet
in front of a critical public audience
well it's the same thing in speaking it
takes about seven years before you have
spoken enough so that you're really good
selling diesel mechanics neurosurgery
Destry Tak seven years law accounting
takes seven years and when you when I
first heard that someone said take will
take you seven years to master your
craft I was had been it for about 3
years I said no darn way not seven years
not me I want took seven years yeah so
people say if you want to if you want to
be one of the highest paid salespeople
in your industry it will take seven
years that's not just seven years of
doing the job you've got to be reading
studying practicing starting earlier
working harder staying later I mean you
have to put it in if you want to achieve
Mastery because there's a lot of
competition out there people say oh gee
you know seven years I mean seven years
from now I'll be I'll be I'll be seven
years older in seven years I'll be 38 in
years so I asked this question I say
really I said now tell me how much older
will you be in seven years in any case
yeah and it stops them I say the only
difference is are you going to be
earning an average wage or going to be
at the top of your field are you going
to be average like most people or you're
going to be one of the highest paid
people in America the time is going to
pass anyway it's one of the great
success principles the time is going to
pass anyway so get on with it because
one of the biggest regrets we have in
life is I put off getting on with the
tool if I had just put my head down when
I was 25 I would be at the top of my
field today well you can't change the
past you could change the future so
start now some people just decide at the
age of 50 by gum I'm going to be one of
the top people now fortunately they
don't have to spend seven years because
they've got a lot of investment and two
to three years of hard work and suddenly
they're earning 10 times what they were
earning before because some people don't
realize how close they are to breaking
through so one of the things I love
about you Brian is you always have
something new you you're always reading
something you're always bringing some
new statistic what is exciting to you
right now what what are the things that
are fascinating you that that you want
to do more research on that you're
learning about that you see as our
immediate future uh what are you
learning and growing with right now well
I I study in a variety of areas I study
uh politics I study economics I study
business I study uh spiritual uh things
uh history and so on my my big thing
right now is the centrality of
Entrepreneurship to uh every society and
what I've concluded and I've started to
write extensively on this is that the
rate of new business formation in any
society determines the health and
prosperity and growth and opportunities
and future of that Society so prosperous
societies have high rates of competent
new business formation and poor
societies have very low rates corrupt
societies have TR our friend from Ghana
will tell you it takes 6 to 18 months to
start a business in Ghana costs
thousands of dollars of corruption and
bribes and once you start in a business
you put a red flag for the corrupt
officials who come around and Shake You
Down every few days and make unable to
do your business so the so the Gans are
some of the most entrepreneurial people
in Africa and they're just totally
frustrated in their ability to break out
well in America you can start a business
overnight and my job my goal my the
things I'm most enthusiastic about is
teaching people how to start and build
successful businesses because these are
skills and every business that goes
broke goes broke because it's like a
ship Founders on a rock is they don't
understand the importance of marketing
or costing or pricing or advertising or
budgeting or planning or organize or or
hiring or delegating or supervising or
or selling or collecting or working with
their Banks and all of these are skills
that entrepreneurs you can either take a
whole life to get them or you can take
them faster so what I'm most excited
about is helping America to become even
more entrepreneurial by not just having
two million people a year start
businesses but having more and more of
them start businesses knowing what
they're doing and then roll it out
worldwide because I think the key to
prosperity for Russia for China
obviously for Latin America for every
country is a vibrant rate of new
business development and that's what
offers more possibilities for more
individuals to achieve more of their
goals to be independent to be
self-reliant to be financially well off
to to achieve all their goals and
abilities so that's what I'm kind of
excited about so somebody's watching
right now and they're working somewhere
working for somebody else at the j o and
they and they say really want I I'm
listening to Brian I listen to the other
people on TSN and I want to be a
millionaire I want to achieve a greater
life for myself and I know that I'm
stuck where I'm at yes and I know that
the key is entrepreneu entrepreneurism
What do I do well the starting point is
to remember this is that the key to
entrepreneurial success is you have to
sell something to somebody you have to
find something at One Price or create it
or build it or buy it or import it or
distribute it and sell it at a higher
price in America you can start there's a
thousand businesses you can start for
less than $25 or less
$50 um multi-level marketing is a high
road most people who go into multi-level
marketing don't make a lot of money in
multi-level marketing but they learn the
business skills that enable them to
succeed at a greater level in other
areas um you can start a small business
on the side sometimes for example give
you an example there a very there a
thriving business in garage sales is
people have garage sales and they're
professional garage sale buyers who are
waiting literally you start your garage
sale at 8:00 Saturday morning they're
there with their trucks they are
developed the ability to pick and choose
and get the best stuff and they
accumulate and then what they do is they
sell it at swap meets they sell it at
antiques or they hold their own garage
sales um and then there's the ultimate
garage sale eBay exactly sell anything
to anybody anywhere absolutely so what
they what there's so many different ways
of doing it but just please understand
key is you have to buy and sell
something people say well I'm not very
good at sales get over it for heaven's
sakes selling you everybody could sell I
mean if if if we sell to our kids to go
to bed on time to clean up their rooms
it's selling and persuasion are skills
that you can learn and once you've
learned the skill of being able to buy
something and then sell it to somebody
else by explaining to them why it's a
good idea that they buy it the more you
do it the better you get at it the
better you get at it the more of it you
can do and so just remember that the
starting point of becoming a self-made
millionaire is to buy and sell a good or
service and to get better and better at
doing this and read the books on
entrepreneurship study your craft learn
what you need to learn and there's
really no limits to what you could
accomplish what top three books would
you recommend the people to
read well in what field you have to tell
me the field General personal
development General personal development
in personal development I would
recommend my book Maxum achievement many
people say it's um as good or maybe the
best ever written it's different from
any of the other success authors uh and
builds on topic um in terms of selling I
would recommend um Advanced selling uh
strategies my book on selling uh in
terms of U business in general I would
recommend the practice of management by
Peter duer in terms of um in terms of
Spiritual Development I would recommend
the book The Sermon on the Mount by by
EMT Fox uh in terms of economics I'd
recommend Lon mises um uh so in history
probably ajp Taylor if you know there
there's every single field uh I love the
idea of of reading books because you get
to sit down with people who you'd never
be able to sit down now granted we're
not sitting down across the table from
them but we're able to hear their ideas
and hear their thoughts and and I don't
think people get that no you know what
what is the importance of of books
here's a couple of points is is first of
all you have you have maintenance
reading and you have growth reading
maintenance reading is magazines
newspapers newsletters uh emails uh
internet uh all that stuff is uh
maintenance reading that keeps you
current with your field does not help
you advance but it keeps your current
you have to do that just like eating the
right Foods growth reading comes only
comes from books is when you read books
that you actually deepen yourself you
actually expand your wisdom and
knowledge you get things out of books
that are almost impossible to get out of
any other shorter Source but the second
thing is is audio listening is I uh my
whole life changed when I discovered
audio listening and the average person
who drives drives 500 to 1,000 hours a
year that's enough to get the equivalent
of a universe the education every year
just listening to really good audios on
your business on sales on relationships
on Health on time management on goals
and so on you can become one of the
smartest and highest paid people in the
world just listening to audios and then
of course watching this program and
watching DVDs that uh have experiences
that you couldn't get without paying
large amounts of money and traveling
great distances so if I were to give the
big three for me for success is number
one take responsibility number two two
is write goals make plans work on them
every day and number three is dedicate
yourself to lifelong learning because
you can learn anything you need to learn
to achieve any goal you can set for
yourself that's good uh I wanted to get
the million dollar habits so let's just
get the $1 million doll habit give me
give me the million doll habit because I
know that's another thing said I will
give you just a double is decide what
you really really really really want in
life Financial Independence and then
make a decision that you will persist
until you succeed you will never give up
until you achieve it make the decision
shut the door behind you as far as
you're concerned is you will never give
up failure is not an option well just
like uh your books and your audio
programs sitting across the table from
you has been fascinating and I
appreciate you being here with us thank
you Chris thanks to see Chris's
interview with Jim ran which was the
last time Jim ran did a video interview
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there what you're about
to watch is the last video interview
that Jim ran ever did he sits down with
Chris White to talk about how to get the
right mentors set meaningful goals and
stop being broke